عجزت الهدن المتعاقبه عن وضع حدا المعارك
في السودان بين الجيش وقوه دعم السريع
وزاد الوضع خطوره دعوات لتسليح المدنيين
قد تودي بالبلاد الى اتوني حرب اهليه ذات
طابع اثنين مدينه الجنينه شهدت هذه الحرب
الاهليه فعلا وقد تمتد لتشمل باقي المناطق
في السودان فاكثر من خمسه الاف قطعه سلاح
تم توزيعها على اسس اثنيه والقوات المسلحه
كانت وجهت دعوات المتكرره لتصليح
المواطنين احتقان الوضع دعا عبد الله
حمدوك رئيس الوزراء السابق للقول ان
السوداني يواجه خطر التفكك محذرا في كلمه
نشرها على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي مطلع
هذا الشهر من ان بلاده تواجه خطر كارثه
انسانيه بعد ان مزقت الحرب العاصمه
الخرطوم وشردت اهلها
اخاطبكم اليوم بصفه المواطن السوداني الذي
يشفق على بلاده واهلها اخاطبكم وبلادنا
تواجه خطر التفكك واقول ان الرصاصه حين
تنفلت من السلاح لن تميز بين المعتدي وغير
المعتدي والضحايا هم السودانيون يجب ان
يتوقف الرصاص فورا ويجب ان يحكم صوت العقل
فالخساره ستكون من نصيب الجميع ولا يوجد
منتصر على جثث شعبي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات